you know i guess if you're an amc
stockholder you'll get a free popcorn
from amc theaters which means one thing
they're behind it to the moon apes
kind of unrelated i just found it
interesting
[Music]
so free guy is a movie starring ryan
reynolds with a pretty clever title
actually is it
free guy as in someone has to free guy
or free guy
because he's broken free of the
algorithm and now he's the master of his
own destiny he's a free guy
or is he a free guy in the sense that he
lives in free city and that makes him a
free guy like i'm a seattle guy
i always respect a title with multiple
interpretations so in free guy ryan
reynolds plays guy he's an npc in a
video game it's pretty much like
gta online then one day he starts going
about his routine differently and
becomes
a character like a player in the game
but with no player pulling his strings
it's pretty much pinocchio a video game
then there's a whole element i didn't
know was in the movie because i didn't
watch the final trailer for free guy and
that's the element
outside the video game in the real world
where taika waititi plays the ceo of the
company that owns this video game he
pretty much is a great interpretation
of many ceos of many video game
companies
in our world so you have joe keary and
jody comer in the real world trying to
work together to figure out what's going
on and how
then you have ryan reynolds and jody
comer in the video game on their
adventure and the two adventures are
linked to jody comber plays
both their video game character and her
player character this one of those
premises where you're like
all you have to do is not screw up this
winning formula it's a character in a
video game who becomes self-aware of
video games
awesome the concept of consciousness
intriguing
it's teed up all you have to do is not
screw it up and luckily
they have the team that didn't screw it
up and they actually do stick the
landings how many times have you seen
that how many times have you seen a
movie where you're like all right
all you have to do is not screw it up
and you did i don't know how
how did you screw that up but you did
almost like it's it's a lot of hard work
to try to [ __ ] that up
to this degree which is why i say the
premise of this movie is simple when you
look at it but it's not easy in
execution
and that's why it's impressive that they
made it work and that does have to do
with the stars in this movie jody comer
has
to have chemistry with joe keary and the
dynamic that they
have together and she also has to have
chemistry with ryan reynolds which is a
very different dynamic that they have
together and it all
has to work ryan reynolds yeah he's ryan
reynolds he plays
that ryan reynolds character that just
it made him famous
it shot him to the top and now it's like
oh that works so that's him yeah he
plays that character in here and i for
one find that damn entertaining i'm not
sick of that yet and now gushing about
the video game element the video game
element in here
i just i loved and i died laughing in
parts because if you know anything about
video games if you play video games
online at all you're gonna see things
that you recognize things that had to be
in this game
someone knocks someone down they do like
the teabag over him it had to happen and
it does
this one of a million little things
you'll see in this game movie
that i just called it a game
i feel like right there it's like yeah
that's how much of a game it feels like
done the review's over but no that's one
of the many things you see in this movie
they do a great job making it feel like
a living video game but if you're not
into video games you don't have to be in
order to enjoy the movie the meat of the
movie is still the adventure the mystery
on one side the action adventure on the
other the easter eggs and references and
all that
those are a nice bonus i appreciated
that and this movie does have an
advantageous freedom in it i've seen a
lot of action adventure movies lately
where i look at it and i'm like that
that feels like a video game in the
sense that the characters just feel
invincible and they're doing impossible
[ __ ] and they don't have superpowers and
i don't know why or how they're living
through any of this but the action in
this movie does take place in a video
game so they have that freedom to go
over the top and it still feels like
it's within the rules of the world and
when you're watching this movie like any
proper movie that takes place in a video
game when it's like oh
we have to save or help the world it
does feel like world scale
but it's a video game world which gives
you that link of one day
maybe it will feel like that maybe a
video game world will feel real that's
another thing i appreciated about this
movie it has the tether it has that dna
it has the link
of the complexity of consciousness and
where does that start and end you know
it doesn't do it as well or as cerebral
as
i thought westworld did it i appreciate
a fun movie that also makes you
contemplate consciousness an enjoyable
action adventure movie that gives you
that little hint of contemplating well
wait are we in a simulation you know the
simulation theory it's a thing i think
about every once in a while and i have
fun and i enjoy doing it i don't even
think it's the point of the movie but
it's what i take away from this movie
it's a large part of it for me in the
end
i really enjoyed free guide there's a
lot that works in free guy
very few things that don't in fact the
things that don't work they haven't
really stuck with me at all
so here we are as a gamer myself i
appreciated the theme but again i don't
think you have to be a gamer to really
have fun with this movie gonna add this
one to my collection i think it's worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray all
right so free guy have you seen it what
did you think about it and do you think
we're all in a simulation
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you